[Music]
we saw a really distinct style of
protest in the form of extinction
rebellion it was announced that the men
are going to try and push prosecution on
all of the activists I saw a Facebook
post that referenced Mahatma Gandhi
first they ignore you first they
ridicule you then they fight you then we
win yeah well it's going to take a
little bit time to win because we're not
just up against the state nor even is
the state the biggest enemy of X are all
of the other groups like me - or black
lives matter even black lives matter
the problem is what what the German
philosopher Hannah Arendt called the
temporary alliance of the elite and the
mob we're up against a temporary
alliance or authoritarian elites who
keep their money offshore who are
heavily invested in fossil fuels
surveillance technologies yeah this is
what these guys and of course based by
investing in offshore that is anti
taxation they're effectively investing
in anti society no that's on one hand
there are large numbers of people who
need to believe that climate change is
not real who need to believe that women
are subordinate to men because if
they're their world will disintegrate in
the next 20 years because of the changes
we need to make your generation cannot
go back into the box that my
grandmother's generation of women could
had to live in or gay men or transgender
people or black people
it isn't we're you can't D Network a
society you can't unliberated generation
ok so X arm for me is the latest
iteration of the new kind of protest
that is there almost the son and
daughter of 2011 and the Occupy movement
the Occupy movement imagined a new
society and we assemble the forms of
that society on the Internet the
networks and then we took it into
physical space in the form of tent camps
and square occupations they didn't last
night they were easily repressed
extinction rebellion me to a black lives
matter take it to a visceral level to a
granular level do you think about what
BLM is saying is that the wages of
whiteness is that ever policeman arrives
on the trouble scene black people get
shot on white people
don't that's why these races spend all
the time on the phone trying to call the
cops on black people for selling water
on the street what they call is the cop
will arrive and shoot somebody and it
ain't going to be there no that's a very
different thing they're saying I need
civil rights
I need civil rights for Martin Luther
King for Malcolm X etc Stokely
Carmichael was real Angela Davis was
real was a real thing
but to say you no longer have the right
to shoot me when the cops turn up he's a
he's a different more granular thing it
demands changes of human behavior b2
demands the change in human behavior I
work in the theater sometimes the
theater is undergoing a revolution
because of the demand of female actors
and producers no longer for that
physical invasion of their body space
under the excuse of the theater not just
talking about director saying you know
let's let's have the drink after work
you know by the way you'll get a lovely
part in my next film
no it's about the actual physicality of
theater is changing there's no a
movement that helps people act through
whether they have to do a sex scene or a
sexual violence scene both these things
exist in reality and should be portrayed
on stage but now we have movements were
remediate those and we allow people to
explore what is happening to them in a
much more reflective way reflective way
than before so what describing though is
the way me too is not just transforming
kind of the agenda of feminism it's
transforming in a real industry it's
also transforming and parts of corporate
life not enough there are no tests and
courses they call them the Weinstein
test in corporate life you can you pass
the test otherwise you don't become a
director of this bank so the amazing
thing is that going back to Exxon that
we've got here what's X our number one
demand tell the truth weird it
philosophies festival we're routinely
people question the possibility of truth
but I don't and I think that's another
thing there are truths they are
provisional they're scientifically
verified we need to fight for them of
course the states are going to repress
it it's gonna be wake up time when some
quite you know I say you know you're
young and therefore inexperienced
protesters my generation of climate
protesters and people I collab
with them reported on I've been trying
to say Luke the cops will come soon
there will be people arriving your camps
here in local unstable you need to deal
with them you did a good way you know
week eight and care for people but what
the cops then do is that they like the
evil doctor they look they look at the
thing and they go that's an entity this
occasionally doesn't have to be our
place another country's police it can be
a private security company you've never
heard of they say one of them what are
the illnesses and weaknesses of this
thing how can we make them worse that's
what happens it's what happened to the
tent camp of Sunland the stock exchange
that it was quite clear
somebody was exacerbating all the
problems and I don't believe it's the
British stage I really you know that the
whole world is no a kind of outsourced
there's kind of state mischief-making
that's outsourced to private companies
we've never heard of you saw it right
around some check Cambridge analytical
this parent company but we can we can
defeat them we are millions of people
and one is more they have sons and
daughters you don't want to live in a
burning planet so in the end we can have
an argument we even would the kind of
shittiest private intelligence company
do you really want to live on a burning
planet with chaos with millions of
refugees unstoppably moving from the
global south to the north if you want to
live in luck on it go on this rocket
into climate change movers if you don't
then even if it might you don't like
people with green hair and those wings
fine just do it yourself Bobby your Tory
MP awesome Republican Congress person
tell them to stop funding climate chaos
for me although I am critical of
institutions like the European Union IMF
World Bank the Bank for International
Settlements has been global but there
are people on the Left who think believe
it's a good idea to break it up break up
the Western order I don't I want to
reform it I want to reform globalization
I think we're going to need big state
intervention into the into the energy
production systems of most big countries
it might need to just be taken by the
state and demobilized very quickly too
but with huge losses for the for the
investors that's something I wouldn't do
unless we really have to do it
but it might need to be done see I just
don't think capitalism can deliver the
amount that the radical change in
consumption of production of energy
behavior that we need in 10 to 15 years
however I'm obliged to accept we need to
try and do it with a radically reformed
form of capitalism we have to give up
wicker the human resources are not there
for an anti-capitalist movement to win
the actions the the corporations are
clinging to the climate model the
economists are clinging to their
economic models so what I want to do in
the next 10 15 years of my life is to
using what we have institutions like
Parliament's economic models climate
science that we have the institutions
that we have to chew a nap that radical
change it will it will probably feel
like a non capitalism the won't be
energy giants that won't be politicians
in the pockets of coal and oil and steel
companies they'll gone if we save the
planet but it might still be a market
economy with a big state sector and in
my project a huge wiki sector a huge
open source collaborative nonprofit
sector that's a good enough goal and 59
I think by the time I die I think we can
actually achieve that by the time you
die we can solve climate change for
modder beit's talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you